well Erica Amy our next guest well she's
stranded in Italy federico romeo is a
student at John Cabot University in Rome
while her family is in Massachusetts
Federica so this is the third week that
we're checking in with you when I first
began talking to you just out the gate
you had a smile on your face you don't
have that same bright smile right now
and I'm not trying to steer you in one
way or the other I want your honest
opinion here tell us what's on your mind
though what what do you want to tell
everyone watching I guess I'd say you
know even though the number of deaths
are constantly rising here it's it's a
pretty tragic in somber situation here I
would just say this isn't a wake-up call
to you know follow the rules stay in
your house then I'm not sure what is at
this point it's unfortunate that I do
have to come and you constantly say
these things on the news like it I would
prefer to do this some other type of way
but it has come to this and then
unfortunately the moment that you know
numbers are going down still having
arrived here in Italy and you know we've
recorded around 800 deaths today and
it's unfortunate and it's sad it's
really sad you know our our hearts with
all the people of Italy and of course
you are fellow American how are you
holding up Federica I mean how are you
getting food and provisions well
essentially it's been a week since I
lost my house I'm probably not going to
leave for another couple of days as for
the what they put in place like we can
still go to the markets to the pharmacy
Libre House for necessary reasons but
apart from that I haven't you know I I'm
receiving news the same way the rest of
the world is I can't really give too
many updates because I don't know much
and you know stuck in my house so
difficult no that's a good point just
wondering if you've kind of got a sense
I just I don't know how you know maybe
emailing fellow if you have any friends
there but let me move on because as we
said you're a senior your senior John
Cabot University there and in Rome which
means you are of a certain age that at
first it was thought that you
were not as vulnerable to the
coronavirus your age group and now
there's a new study saying that your age
group is so what is it that you would
like to directly say to some of your
fellow Millennials because it's probably
better hearing it from you than me um I
would just say to you know take me as an
example a couple weeks ago I didn't even
think I thought the impossible would
have never happened and it happened so
you know be safe be smart make smart
decisions just starts being in your
house spend time with your family during
this time I think that's really
important I can't so I mean I'm we're
kind of all on the same boat here in
Italy all other students that have
remained and you know we're just we're
just trying to be grateful and you know
learn the bigger lesson of all of us
because there will be a bigger lesson
and I think that America can take the
lesson that we are experiencing here in
Italy and it'll be really helpful to
kind of like figure out the path that
this will go on and if we can stop it
eventually and as I said your families
in Massachusetts I'm sure you're able to
FaceTime with them or email with them
what are you showing to them because I'm
sure you're there they're concerned
about you what are you talking about
they're concerned we're taking it like
it's a day-by-day situation my mom is
more updated than anybody else I know
probably on the coronavirus comm she
sends me constantly you know it's the
daily statistics of it all she keeps me
updated I'm really grateful for that as
well but we were taking it day by day
like I said we're not sure when I'll be
home I'm not too you know up to date on
with the travel restrictions are
currently so I'm not sure but I was
looking at price of tickets they're
still about $2,000 but like I said it's
not about the price it's more about the
risk and we're gonna wait it out but
they miss me and I'm well you stay safe
and you stay healthy and maybe I'll get
a chance to talk to you again next week
I really appreciate your your time
Serena's time with us villarrica from
that's good luck take care of